the killing of Tyree Nichols an unarmed
black man pulled over in a regular
traffic stop by five police officers in
Memphis Tennessee has reignited the
perennial debate over race and policing
now this case is different from the
other prominent officer-involved
killings that have preceded it George
Floyd Michael Brown Brianna Taylor in
that Not only was the deceased person
black but all of the officers involved
in his death were also black and it all
took place in Memphis a city that is 65
percent black
nevertheless former Congressman Democrat
monder Jones warns people not to be
distracted by those facts if you think
Jones wrote the Memphis police officers
had to be white in order to exhibit
anti-blackness you need to take that AP
African-American studies course Ron
DeSantis just banned
yes
everyone involved was black
but they were still motivated by
anti-blackness which is just another
woke Buzz term meaning white supremacy
as viral Libs have rushed to point out
on social media
I got a message today for some white
people if we have white people
listening paying attention I wouldn't
mind if you would do this with me we rub
our chests we find our heartbeat
and we say we did this
we did this
white supremacy did this
I'm talking about
Tyree Nichols
the police didn't do this
the Memphis Police Department didn't do
this
white supremacy did this
the cops have been arrested they're
presumed innocent until proven guilty
even though the video evidence that we
have is pretty damning but by the
standard of the left viral nobodies and
prominent politicians alike even if the
cops are convicted it wasn't really the
cop's fault
according to many on the left the
responsibility for Tyree Nichols is
killing and really for all the evils in
the world lies with white people and
their alleged system of white supremacy
even when the white people are nowhere
in sight I'm Michael Knowles of the
Michael Knowles show
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment on Fridays from Frank s who says
I like how that Pfizer executive had to
tell the 911 dispatcher that there were
five white men around him this wasn't
shown in Michael's video after he
committed multiple felonies of assault
and robbery I I guess I didn't catch
that part in the video but but I'm I'm
not surprised at all I think I just he's
smashing equipment he's taking swings at
people he's trying to tackle James
O'Keefe he says wait
hold on a second I can play the victim
card these guys are not letting me
attack them these guys they're they're
threatening me by by being there while I
attack them I might I might hurt my fist
on their face you know when when you
want to have conversations with your
friends over the phone that are much
more coherent than that you gotta check
out pure talk right now go to
puretalk.com enter promo code Knowles if
one of your goals this year is to do
business with companies who share your
beliefs then you got to check out Pure
Talk Pure Talk is the antidote to woke
wireless companies it is proudly veteran
owned employs a us-based customer
service team and absolutely refuses to
spend money on fake news networks not to
mention Pure Talk service is fantastic
they are one of the largest networks in
the country you can get blazing fast
data talk and text for as low as 30
bucks a month it's probably half of what
you're paying Verizon ATT or T-Mobile
switch over to Pure Talk in as little as
10 minutes while keeping your phone and
your phone number
your first month is guaranteed risk-free
try it if you're not completely happy
with the service you will get your money
back this year make it a goal to support
companies that support you go to
puretalk.com enter promo code Knowles
kwles to save 50 on your first month
that is puretalk.com promo code Knowles
kwles Pure Talk is
quite simply
simply smarter Wireless
the video of that white liberal lady
saying that even though
even though all the cops involved in the
killing of Tyree nickels are black even
though Memphis is a black City even
though white people were nowhere to be
seen she says beat your chest beat your
chest white people this is our fault
this shows you a point that I've made
for years now which is that racism white
supremacy all these terms are just just
uh synonyms in our modern culture for
evil it's so it's always got to be white
people's fault the the
ultimate sin is racism and and by racism
specifically
racism from white people white supremacy
white nationalism whatever you want to
call it and what what she is doing is
expressing a weird modern lib version of
the true and traditional doctrine of
original sin
she's even beating her breast in in
Christianity what we do is we beat our
breasts and we say
Maxima culpa
the the understanding of original sin is
that we in our sins have killed Christ
we have slain Christ because Christ is
Incarnate to die for mankind to redeem
Mankind from his sins because we all
sinned in Adam when Adam first took that
bite of the apple and lost his paradise
and sin and death pervaded the world so
we in a very real sense are responsible
for Killing Jesus you might say well we
weren't walking around first century
Palestine doesn't matter we because of
our fallen Humanity which is not just
some weird thing that we're imagining it
is an observable fact this is a fallen
world and we all sin so that part
totally observable obviously true uh the
understanding is that we are born with
that and so we we carry a real fault and
we continue to sin in our thoughts and
in our words and what we do and what we
fail to do now the Liberals intuiting
this fact of human nature
reject all of the all of the stuff that
goes with it the Liberals reject that
God exists often they reject that we
need a savior who comes outside of us
they reject they reject everything about
our traditional culture and the religion
that animates our traditional culture
but they realize that these facts still
exist and so they just have to transmute
them into some weird new leftist
religion and so what they do is they
transmute that into a literal beating of
the chest over white supremacy which is
not the cause of it very often you will
hear people say the original sin in
America is slavery or at a broader level
the original sin of America is racism
that isn't true
all that stuff is there's plenty of bad
stuff that happens in America and other
places around the world
but the original sin of America is
original sin and when you try to try to
translate that into some weird modern
religion where you get rid of God and
you get rid of all the all the stuff
that undergirds it you end up sounding
like wackos like that liberal lady on
Tick Tock and like Monday Jones
white supremacy did not cause this
killing we we don't really know
The crucial fact here
which is what happened before the video
came on
there's video footage now body cam
footage
dash cam footage has been released
officers to Darius Bean
Demetrius Haley Emmett Martin the third
Desmond Mills Jr and Justin Smith
have all been charged with two counts of
official misconduct uh one count of
official oppression second-degree murder
obviously the biggest one there
aggravated assault act in concert and
two counts of aggravated kidnapping
the video footage looks very very bad
there is there is one question that
remains which is why did they pull this
guy over they say that they pulled him
over for reckless driving
the head of police in Memphis says that
we don't have evidence of that yet so we
don't know really the cameras kind of
click on as this is happening
so you don't really see the earliest
parts of this encounter then uh Tyree
Nichols resists arrest and runs away and
then they get him and they basically
just beat this guy to death he doesn't
die on the scene they don't get a
medical attention he dies later at the
hospital it's really damning stuff it's
hard to imagine these guys are going to
get off the hook for it but
in this country people are innocent
until proven guilty so we'll see if
anything comes out on trial as to why
they pulled him over in the first place
why this escalated so quickly one theory
that is going around right now
a very Politically Incorrect theory is
that these cops were hired with lowered
standards so this is a theory a law
enforcement official Karen parmar says
according to a source within the Memphis
PD the five officers charged were not
hired through the usual PD hiring
process city leaders felt the existing
process was too strict and kept certain
people from getting jobs at the
department city leaders began their own
hiring process and then pushed new hires
into the agency bypassing the testing
procedures in place at the department
we know that this sort of thing happens
there's a big lawsuit about this in New
Haven some years ago because first
responder exams uh allegedly there
weren't enough people of certain
demographics there wasn't enough
diversity in the department and so they
lowered the standards
um and it happens whether it happened
here it remains to be seen but it is
being reported by multiple outlets and
this this is
one of the weaknesses with democracy
this is one of the weaknesses that the
founding fathers wrote about framers
wrote about that political thinkers have
have recognized throughout history which
is that if a regime becomes too
Democratic you have a leveling and so
it's not that everybody is raised up to
the highest levels of Excellence but
rather that everybody becomes sort of
handicapped like Kurt Vonnegut writes
about in Harrison Bergeron or like we
see today just a lowering of Standards
okay not enough people that we want to
get into certain schools or not get are
getting into certain schools so we're
just going to get rid of the SAT we're
gonna get rid of the ACT we're going to
lower the entry exams to become a copper
to become a firefighter we're uh not
enough women are in the military we want
more women in the military let's lower
the physical requirements to get into
the military and so it's just it becomes
a lowering to the lowest common
denominator and and you you see this in
the writing of our founding fathers
that's why they did not give us a
democracy that's why they write so
disparagingly about democracy uh it's
why they didn't even give us
quite a republic or just a
representative democracy in that the
American form of government really
includes aspects of all three types of
government there are three types of
government
monarchy aristocracy and democracy and
according to the ancient writer polybius
those are the three good versions of
that government it's not that only one
of those is good the other two are
terrible all three can be good but they
have a corrupted version too the
corruption of monarchy is tyranny the
corruption of aristocracy is oligarchy
the corruption of democracy is Mob Rule
and and uh he he views this as a kind of
cycle of regimes that is constantly
going to evolve so what the American
Founders and framers tried to do is
establish a regime that includes aspects
of all of them you have a monarchical
element in the strong executive in the
president you have an aristocratic
element it's certainly in the Senate and
elsewhere in the government a
representation for the landed classes
especially when there were more
stringent voting requirements and it was
just a more of an arrest credit kind of
a society and then obviously a very
strong Democratic representation too is
that what happened here we don't know
it's going to go to trial but regardless
even even in this case where the facts
are so clear was there a white person in
sight it doesn't look like it very very
few if any nevertheless you are going to
see the popular press
just
absurdly try to blame this on the usual
old culprit white supremacy the reason
they're going to do that is because that
phrase is simply a byword for evil in
the Fallen nature of man
in modern America
now
this is not to let the cops off the hook
here
conservatives are generally strong
Defenders of cops I am a strong defender
of cops I'm especially a strong defender
of cops in Memphis I don't know how many
of you have ever been to Memphis Memphis
is a very dangerous place Memphis is one
of two places in this country that I
have ever been jumped or very nearly
jumped the other was on the Jersey Shore
where I Used to Vacation a lot as a kid
the other one was in Memphis I was in
Memphis for one night back in I want to
say this is
I was probably 10 years ago more than
that probably at this point and
I I was stopping off in Memphis with a
buddy of mine we went to Beale Street
which is the main drag had some drinks
had a couple coca-colas listen to some
music then we were walking back we were
probably two blocks off of Beale Street
uh it kind of stood out like a sore
thumb smoking cigars I was probably
wearing some silly colored polo shirt
but we're walking we see some guy it
looked like he was either breaking into
a car or he looked like he was up to no
good and we hear hey fellas I said I
don't want to talk to this guy we walk
in the other direction he starts walking
he goes fellas fellas he starts walking
after us we start walking faster he
starts walking faster we run he starts
running after us finally and we had
cigars so we didn't want to just go
inside but we see a hotel so we get in
front of the hotel there's obviously a
huge camera right there we're right in
front of the opening and closing doors
and this guy stops running right outside
the the frame of the camera he can see
the camera too he's a little bit further
out he goes hey guys you come you want
to come over here
said that no there's all
can you can you give me some money
said no it was oh it was can you pray
for me
we said yes
yes we can pray for you absolutely
and I kid you not he goes can you pray
for me over here he's still trying so
desperately hey come on over here so I
can jump you and steal your money this
was two blocks off Beale Street the main
part of Memphis okay
so I don't think Memphis is going to be
served by taking cops off the streets I
think probably Memphis needs many more
cops on the streets
but you still need training you still
need high standards and you still need
just as served I mean you can't you
can't allow just roving gangs of
untrained cops to go around terrorizing
people we'll see what happens I'm
probably the the only commentator in all
of America who who thinks that we should
wait to see what comes out at trial
before totally forming our opinions but
facts certainly don't look good and then
the cops really don't look good in San
Francisco so you remember the Paul
Pelosi break-in Nancy Pelosi is out of
town 9-1-1 call at the Pelosi residence
in San Francisco
cops come Paul Pelosi is a according to
the reports in his boxers and then
there's this guy who I guess broke in
but Paul Pelosi doesn't seem concerned
and then according to reports Paul
Pelosi said that he knew the guy
referred to him as a friend
that that Paul Pelosi didn't rush to the
cops when they got there and then
finally the guy attacked Paul Pelosi
with a hammer but all sorts of theories
based on the Press reports well now we
got the video footage
the cops show up to the door it's
unclear who opens the door what's going
on man everything's good
hi drop the hammer um
hey hey the guys hold us
and that guy just attacks Paul Pelosi
with a hammer
[Applause]
so it's a little bit weird here you
don't we don't really know who opens the
door it's Paul Pelosi they're standing
somewhat still he's got a drink it could
be just a glass of water in one hand and
then his arm is being held by this this
Invader in the other hand the invader
then has the hammer in the other hand
and they're all just standing there and
the cops go hey what's going on here
so your first thought is why didn't the
cops tackle this guy this guy's holding
a hammer
he's holding a hammer
while holding Paul Pelosi the husband of
the Speaker of the House of
Representatives and the cops are just
waiting there like hey what's going on
hey man Drop The Hammer drop the hammer
the guy's got a hammer he's got the
husband the speaker of the house I bet
you jump on him I bet you shoot him how
about you do something are you standing
there and then they wait and then the
guy just slowly takes the hammer out and
smacks Paul Pelosi on the head
so that's bad enough it's weird though
because there are still questions why
doesn't Paul Pelosi seem uh more nervous
why doesn't who open the door what do
these guys know each other what what is
this do the cops not know that this is
Paul Pelosi but then we get the 9-1-1
call and Things become much clearer
this is San Francisco police do you need
help
oh well the gentleman uh uh here just
waiting for my wife to come back
nasty policy okay do you need to please
fire a medical for anything eight
seconds uh I I don't think so I don't
think so I've got a problem but he
thinks everything's good
this element just uh came into the house
uh and he wants to wait here for my wife
to come home zero and so uh four and 40.
do you know who the person is
no I don't know who he is he uh
I could do anything apparently this this
gentleman says
yeah he told me to put the phone down
and you see what he said my name David
the name is David
okay and who is David I don't know right
I'm a friend of theirs
yeah I I um he says he's a friend but
you don't know who he is no it's no mess
he's telling me I'm being very leading
so I I gotta stop talking to you okay
you sure I can tell
you fell off the phone
okay okay
thank you okay bye
so this goes that's just a brief snippet
of it the CL the the call goes on and
the longer the call goes on the angrier
one becomes
at the incompetence of this dispatcher
because hey I'm here there's a guy in my
house I don't know him he says he's
going to wait for my wife Nancy Pelosi
um she goes oh yeah okay do you need
emergency services or no okay and I
later on she goes okay well call back if
you need anything he's going no I don't
what do you no why and you you realize
that Paul Pelosi is telegraphing as
clearly as he possibly can that they
need to send someone immediately and
this incompetent dispatcher it is ready
to hang up the phone he said no no don't
hang what are you and and you can hear
the guy
the guy comes in he says hey I'm a
friend I don't I don't know him but he
says that he's a friend of ours and and
she almost hangs up so
this dispels the conspiracy theories
the conspiracy theories were popular as
he knew the guy they one conspiracy
theory was that they were gay lovers the
uh there were all sorts of theories
floating around the internet and
the the reason the theories were
floating around the internet is not
because
right-wingers are insane
the reason the theories were floating
around the internet is because that was
the information that was reported the
information that was reported was that
this guy that Paul Pelosi referred to
this guy as a friend
that that the police on another one of
the dispatcher transcripts says that
that this guy was a friend of Pelosi
the Pelosi was cool and calm and
collected didn't rush to the police had
a drink in his hand had his pants off
all of the leaks
before this information came out
suggested that these guys had some kind
of a relationship so then the question
is
who released the information who was
behind the leaks and the answer is it
was only it was the cops the cops are
the only ones that had and the the
political leadership of the cops they're
the only ones that had the tapes
so you had on the one hand you had the
left-wing theory that this was a right
winger a trump Republican he's obviously
not he was a nudist with a gay pride
flag at one of the compounds that he was
living at he's an illegal alien he's
obviously completely insane so that
theory goes out the window then you have
the the right wing theory on the fringes
that this guy was
I don't know a gay lover or something
like that but that one goes out and so
you had the left and the right bickering
with each other when really what is
revealed by the 911 tape is
this was the cops covering up for their
incompetence
very very bad week for cops in this
country
now what's the solution to that there
are really only two solutions I think
listening to this kind of incompetence
and then especially looking at the
outrage that people see from from the
police involved killing of Tyree Nichols
either you can just disband the police
either the libs were right abolish the
police these guys are or
fund the police much better train them
much better exclude people from the
forest who are not up to the job fire
that dispatcher fire the cops who
improperly responded to the the Pelosi
call and and just or train them or just
get get
much better policing I think the answer
is obviously the latter
it can't be the former because contrary
to what the libs and the sort of anarcho
libertarian kind of right-wing Libs
would have you believe the civil
government exists to protect Law and
Order we need it we need Law and Order
we need a civil authority to have a
flourishing Society
is we're not just free-floating atoms
left to do what we want we'll all build
up our own private armies that's not
real that's never happened anywhere
that's a utopian fantasy what what we
need is Law and Order and so if that's
the basis of a society then we need good
strong police departments with good
training and high standards and legal
protections for the cops so they don't
have their lives ruined by political
correctness if they are involved in a
Justified police involved killing which
very often what happens now is police
are involved in a Justified killing a
Justified shooting and then they go to
prison and then or they get their lives
ruined in some other way they lose their
careers they lose their pensions and so
a lot of good people a lot of good
competent people say why would I ever
want to be a cop
there's no political defense of me it's
a dangerous job and I could lose my life
if I trespass against the virtues of
political devices of political
correctness
so then then you end up in a bad
situation you end up in a very bad
Personnel situation
the smart politicians though are trying
to beef up police and Law and Order the
right way
one such politician a man who's getting
a lot of headlines right now because
he's very obviously running for
president in 2024 that would be Ron
DeSantis Rhonda Santos is getting
tougher on crime down in Florida
DeSantis is strengthening Florida's bail
laws by limiting who is eligible for
release prior to first appearance this
is good because in in places like New
York and elsewhere around the country
you
these criminals get brought in they get
arrested then they're released on zero
dollars bail or Bond very low uh
Financial requirements to get out they
go out and they commit more crimes you
especially saw this during the George
Floyd riots so he's doing that they'll
petition the Florida Supreme Court to
establish a uniform Bond schedule
they will toughen penalties for sex
criminals
they'll require law enforcement to
report missing persons to the National
system dedicate five million dollars to
continue uh uh to to continue to fund
the police and especially uh drug forces
and then here's one uh require convicted
child rapists to serve at least life in
prison and explore options to make them
eligible for the death penalty so
getting very tough on crime in principle
I agree with all of this stuff one
little wrinkle I would say is I I don't
know that it is smart to
execute people for rape and the reason
for that is not because they don't
deserve it the reason for that is not
because I think we should go soft on
rapists or anything like that but it's a
pure political calculation which is if
the punishment for rape is the same as
the punishment for murder then there is
no incentive for rapists not to murder
their victims and so this would be an
example where I think people's passions
and desires and sense for justice could
outweigh their prudence and they'll say
well who cares I think we should just
have capital punishment for everybody
okay but if you do that then you might
imprudently end up in a situation where
where someone who's a rapist is going to
to kill his victim because if he kills
this victim then she'll certainly be
silent and if he gets caught well it's
going to be the same punishment either
way so other than that you know and I I
think they'll try to work that out but
obviously DeSantis is moving in the
right direction here uh which is get
tougher on crime these things come in
waves and the left and the right at
various times are more pro cop or less
pro cop the left which out of one side
of its math talks about how we need to
abolish the police out of the other side
of his mouth says that we need to trust
the FBI and essentially let the FBI run
the government
so okay we don't like local law
enforcement but we do like federal law
enforcement the conservatives at various
times are very much more for Law and
Order then sometimes they feel a little
more libertarian and they say we need to
protect our civil liberties and and
reduce the number of cops and reduce the
number of criminal offenses that the
cops could even enforce but generally
speaking
conservatives should be pro cop we
should just rather than try to have some
lame ideological solution where we write
it on the back of a napkin and say these
are the five bullet points that are
going to create the perfect Society
rather than say we've either got to
abolish the cops or you know have
unleash a paramilitary on our nation I
think the smarter solution is
how could we just how can we improve
policing how can we we fund them give
them more money beef them up a little
bit but have higher requirements so you
weed out some of the bad cops how do we
how do we work in an imperfect world in
real institutions without just trying to
blow the whole thing up as
revolutionaries on the left and the
right have sought to do since time
immemorial speaking of presidential
candidates president Trump the only
declared or
I think he's the only decline did Mike
Pence officially say he's running or he
just said he's probably going to run
Nikki Haley just said she's probably
going to run Joe Biden has now declared
that he's running but he's obviously not
campaigning yet Trump is running he's
declared he's hit
New Hampshire and South Carolina here is
the campaign message from New Hampshire
when I announce I just want to put my
cards in the table you know we're
playing that very big game right now the
biggest game of all because it involves
the country and the survival of the
United States of America but when I uh
when I put the cards on and then I said
all right let's go they said he's not
campaigning this is like
about a month ago when I announced well
I said you know I got two years
they said he's not doing rallies he's
not campaigning maybe he's lost that
step by we didn't I'm more angry now and
I'm more committed now than I ever was
because
Okay so
Trump is acknowledging the criticism of
his campaign and his campaign loss
and it would seem that he's reacting to
it too because he starts now doing
events but he didn't do a big rally this
was an event really for locals and the
Republican leadership in New Hampshire
and then he says this line I'm angrier
now
than I've ever been before
but the way he says it he doesn't seem
angry
nor necessarily should he seem angry
he's Trump running in 2024 is a very
different thing than Trump running in
2016. he's a different person he's got
different experience he brings a
different ethos to the whole to the
whole matter but you you can the only
thing you can really tell I think I
agree with Trump he's got two years I
agree that a lot of the criticism of his
campaign is BS I agree that it's mostly
just people on the left and the right
who hate his guts and the people on the
left are trying to stop him from running
and the people on the right who are
attacking him now probably in most cases
are people who hated him in 2016 also so
all of that is true but
I think it is fair to say he doesn't
seem to have the same fire he doesn't
seem to have the same focus when he came
down that escalator in 2015 he said the
the illegal aliens they're rapists and
they're murderers they're being sent
across we need to build a big wall and
Deport all these people who are invading
our country
love it or hate it that's a clear
message we're getting screwed on trade
deals we're going to stick it to China
we're going to completely upend
America's trade policy love it or hate
it that is a very clear message it
distinguished him from the others in the
crowd
now just by virtue of the fact that he
was already the president it's it's
going to be harder to distinguish
himself from the rest of the party he
recreated the party after his own image
so I think he's going to have to try
something different he then hit South
Carolina and announced a big leadership
team and he got a big endorsement from
that state senator Lindsey Graham
there's one thing I want to talk to you
about
how many
how many times have you heard we like
Trump
uh policies but we want somebody new
there are no Trump policies without
Donald Trump
I was there
you know why 400 billion
dollars given by NATO Nations because he
asked and they were afraid to say no
up there is asked NATO to get more money
but they gave more money when he asked
people talk about China you did
something about China they finally paid
everybody's been talking about China you
made them pay you know why Mexico said
yes to you because she scared the hell
out of them by taking on China we live
in a dangerous world right now
the good news for the Republican party
there are many many talented people for
years to come but there is only one
Donald Trump
and I say this sincerely
you can talk about his policies but you
could not do what he did
this is the message that Trump has to
drive home and it's funny that it's
coming from Lindsey Graham because
Lindsey Graham is considered kind of a
Squish and they call him Lindsey
gramnisty and all sorts of things and
Graham was very opposed to Trump in
2016. he obviously ran against him then
he became much more supportive of Donald
Trump and I don't care if you love
Lindsey Graham or you hate Lindsey
Graham One Lindsey Graham is a great
trial lawyer and he's very good at
getting himself reelected and he's he's
just a very talented politician even if
you think he's a big squish lib and so
the fact that Lindsey Graham is putting
his money on Donald Trump
does tell you a little something about a
political calculation Lindsey Graham
feels that the political wind is still
blowing in the direction of Donald Trump
and Lindsey Ramsey hit on the campaign
message that Trump needs which is there
is no trumpism without Trump
the DeSantis campaign message is there
is trumpism without Trump I am the
better version of trump I am more
disciplined I am better educated I am I
I'm better able to make deals I'm less
polarizing I'm whatever the whole list
of Ron desantis's campaign pitch
it essentially boils down to I am Trump
but better and so Trump's campaign
message has to be there is no better
Trump I'm I'm Trump I'm unique I'm an
American original there's nobody like me
there's a lot of imitators out there but
I'm the only one who can do it and even
if we both have the same policies
I can get it done and there's more to
politics than just policy on a sheet of
paper I can get it done
now what DeSantis argument is going to
be actually I got it done better than
you did
and then Trump's argument is going to be
you could never have done any of that
without me one you wouldn't have gotten
elected without me but two if I didn't
give you political cover from the
national level you wouldn't have been
able to do a good job as governor and
that's going to be the battle
but but if the issue it just comes down
to issues I don't know that Trump is
going to win
because the party and the smart
politicians in the party
have taken a page out of Trump's book
and adopted his positions on issues
positions that seven eight years ago
would not have been acceptable on
immigration on trade on the the
involvement of the government and the
daily lives of Americans that would not
have been on foreign policy for that
matter
so the only way that Trump can
distinguish himself is by saying I'm the
one who can do it I do it in a different
way the fact that I am polarizing the
fact that I am Brash the fact that I am
unpredictable the fact that I'm not
totally educated in this uh politician
University kind of way
that is my plot it's not a negative
that's my plus and that's the message
that Lindsey Graham has honed in on and
I think it's a very strong one if he can
if he can make a persuasive case for
that thesis the nomination probably is
still his don't forget we're talking
about especially Rhonda Santos because
he's just so impressive in Florida
you're seeing desantis's numbers shoot
up out of nowhere up to a pretty
respectable number
now what is he now he's at 30 or
something even higher but
Trump is still way up
the the primary contest remains trumps
to lose but he's got some big weaknesses
especially when it comes to covid which
we'll get to in one second first up
if you're a parent you know that the
radical left is infiltrated every aspect
of your kids lives from Academia to
medicine to Children's programming
they're pushing a woke agenda at every
turn and doing everything they can to
capture their hearts and Minds if you're
a parent then it is deeply deeply
concerning you may feel powerless to
stop the onslaught but the good news is
that many are finding a way to fight
back that is why I'm excited to tell you
about a brand new book published by DW
books written by Bethany Mandel and
Carol Markowitz it's called
stolen youth how radicals are erasing
innocence and indoctrinating a
generation in stolen youth they share
testimonies from parents who are just
witnessing and now how far and out of
control agenda is corrupting our morals
okay and uh one that was exacerbated
during the pandemic this is an absolute
must read for parents who want to
understand how we got here what we're up
against how to go on the offensive and
how to save our kids stolen youth how
radicals are erasing innocence and
indoctrinating a generation comes out
March 7th but if you click on the Amazon
Link in the description you can
pre-order your copy today go do it
pre-order the copy of that book
Senator Ron Johnson
is standing up for the vaccine injured
he says the vaccine injured deserved to
be seen heard and believed
and then he tags a news agency says are
you aware of the covid-19 vaccine
injuries in the aviation industry
my letter highlights five of these
severe Adverse Events experienced by
pilots and an air traffic controller so
you got Ron Johnson has this this letter
that he's put out and and it's now being
reported in a number of places including
the epoch times of of Pilots
specifically who all had to get the
stupid fouchy ouchy and many of whom
have suffered adverse uh events now
he says well it remains unclear what if
anything the FAA has done as it relates
to these individuals experiences or if
it is actively monitoring covid-19
adverse effects in the aviation industry
as of January 13th there's the vaccine
adverse event Reporting System recorded
more than one and a half million adverse
effects and 33 746 deaths associated
with the covid-19 vaccines and
I think a lot of people hear that number
from bears and they say oh well verus is
unverified and so that's that number is
actually probably overblown no it's the
opposite time and time again we see
evidence that veres actually drastically
under reports
vaccine injuries
now think about this do you know anyone
in your life
who has suffered a vaccine injury or do
you know someone who knows someone who
suffered a vaccine injury
most people I think do I certainly do
and I think most people know someone or
know someone who knows someone who
suffered a vaccine injury then ask
yourself did that person file a report
with the vaccine Adverse Events
reporting system
usually not
most people will not do or even you
might say well I got my kid got this
vaccine and then things started to seem
a little weirder yeah I started to have
these I don't know kind of shortness of
breath or heart problems or this or that
but I'm not gonna I don't know I don't
want to seem like a crazy person so
there's under reports that how many
people actually died from this vaccine
Vera says 33 746 I bet that number is
much much higher in addition a
Department of Defense whistleblower
provided Ron Johnson's office with data
quote showing an increase in disease and
injuries in Pilots across the dod in
years 2020 to 2022 compared to years
2016 to 2019.
now there will be debate they'll you'll
hear the libs say well no the the the
adverse effects were caused by the the
virus not by the vaccine no no it's just
a viral you know the virus was
everywhere it's caused by the virus not
the vaccine
that merits some study because what what
little evidence is available now doesn't
seem to suggest that and furthermore the
fact that we're not even allowed to
raise that question
tells you I think everything you need to
know the fact that if you raise that
question
you can in many circumstances be kicked
off of social media
you will be looked on as as a as an
idiot you'll you'll be called a
misinformer you'll you'll be accused of
of committing something tantamount to
murder
because you're spreading Health
misinformation
and then to tie it back to the political
2024 question this is Trump's biggest
weakness
and this is I suspect we're DeSantis and
any other challenges are going to hit
Trump the hardest
is they're going to say you promoted
this vaccine
this vaccine was bad news
and so what Trump is going to do and
you're already starting to see this is
Trump is going to start to hit DeSantis
there he's going to say what do you
promoted the vaccine too
and you locked down too don't pretend
that you didn't lock down you locked
down for months
and you're already seeing Trump start to
make that attack so even now 2024 this
will be four years after covet 19.
I strongly suspect that much of the
Republican primary is going to come down
to covid we are still processing the
covid lockdowns
and and we think we've moved on because
we don't wear the stupid hankies anymore
over our face and even the people who
formerly took were very afraid of covid
and who promoted the vaccines and who
even
most of those people virtually all of
those people on the right have come back
to reality and said okay actually yeah
that was crazy we shouldn't have given
up our rights we shouldn't have locked
down shouldn't have worn the stupid
hanky shouldn't have taken the vouchi
algae okay all right fine but
just because the people on the right now
broadly agree on on what we should have
done
it doesn't mean that we're past it that
was a national trauma people died alone
people were not allowed to say goodbye
to their loved ones kids were taken out
of school it's seriously damaged their
education and their socialization
the the good news about taking kids out
of school is that it it prevented them
from learning a bunch of insane nonsense
from their woke teachers that was a good
thing it prevented their socialization
in the sense that it stopped them from
becoming socialists more quickly but it
it did seriously harm them the fact that
kids weren't allowed to see their
friends seriously harmed their
development
destroyed our economy destroyed small
businesses was the largest transfer of
wealth in recorded history from the
lower classes to the upper classes it
was a major transfer of our political
rights
away from communities and away from
American citizens toward unelected
unaccountable bureaucrats who hate our
guts
we're still we've still got to Grapple
with that
if you think we're just going to move on
you're you're I've I've got a bridge in
Brooklyn to sell you speaking of
speaking of kovid
you know
the the covid
or rather the Pfizer video that I
referenced earlier in my favorite
comment of the day has created quite a
splash that that Pfizer executive who
thought he was out on a date with a man
and then the man turned out to be a
Honeypot plant and James O'Keefe walks
in and says hey we got you on video
admitting that Pfizer is performing gain
of function research and directed
Evolution research to beef up viruses
and then the kid just loses his mind I
say kid he's a he's a young man he's I
think 31. in fact I know he's in his
early 30s because a a classmate of mine
from college reminded me I went to
college with that guy that Pfizer guy
that was caught on tape by project very
tough he was one year below me in
college and his his face is familiar I I
didn't know him personally some of my
friends knew him him personally and once
I heard that I said oh this all makes
sense this guy is behaving exactly as
you would expect a a modern liberal Yale
to behave
he's
ruthlessly ambitious he is a liar he's
in his first excuse was I'm a liar I'm
literally a liar I was lying about that
he's
he's engaged in Fairly nefarious
activities uh that that he is justifying
according to his his own liberal mores
totally divorced from traditional
morality he's on a gay date at sir you
know Yale University is the gayest
University in the Western Hemisphere
probably in the entire world and he's
he's uh
he really melts down when he's told no
when when when a conservative and he's
probably met a handful of conservatives
in his entire life
pushes back and says hey we're not going
to let you do that we're going to expose
you for engaging and gain of function
research which is very very dangerous it
possibly illegal and certainly immoral
and we're just not going to let you do
it and he just loses starts throwing the
iPad starts running around tries to play
the race card apparently according to
that commenter earlier just a complete
meltdown Pfizer's finally responded
Pfizer finally said allegations have
recently been made
related to gain of function and directed
Evolution research at Pfizer and the
company would like to set the record
straight in the ongoing development of
the Pfizer bioen Tech covid-19 vaccine
Pfizer has not conducted gain of
function or directed Evolution research
I don't really believe that I'm going to
parse that sentence because maybe the
sentence is true
but I don't think that the implication
is true
in the ongoing development
of the covid-19 vaccine Pfizer has not
conducted gain a function or directed
Evolution research so has not done it
does not necessarily contradict what the
guy said in the video because the Pfizer
executive in the video
was stating more that Pfizer is looking
into doing this that they think that
this would be a way to get ahead of
vaccine development so it doesn't
necessarily
mean that they have already engaged in
this kind of research it could be that
they simply plan to engage in that and
it would make sense that uh the the guy
in the Pfizer video would know that
because he's apparently a worldwide
director for mRNA research advisor
has not conducted gain a function or
directed Evolution research has Pfizer
already conducted that kind of search
outside of the ongoing development of
the of the covid-19 vaccine because
they're very specific there they say in
the development of this vaccine we don't
engage in gain and function
well have you have you elsewhere and are
you planning to for the covid-19 vaccine
and why did it take you
damn near a week to come up with this
excuse
at least several days why did it take
you so long to say no
do you trust these people I don't trust
these people
at all
that's why you're seeing a big
flip right now
the right used to be the side that
believed all the scientists and the left
used to be the side that was anti-vaxx
and anti-moncanto and anti-corporate
food and anti all that that has
completely flipped that has flipped in
large part because of covid when I say
that our politics today
is largely a reaction to not code not
the virus but a reaction to what the
virus and the subsequent political
reaction exposed about our political
system I mean to the point that now all
the crunchy granola hippie people
they're on the right they're not on the
left all the anti-vaxxers they're on the
right they're not on the left
even if the even if those people don't
quite know it yet they are Veer all the
anti-seed oil kind of memes and cultural
bubblings up that you're seeing it's on
the right it's not on the left and the
shill for the people in the lab coats in
the big executive office Towers trying
to stick your arm full of poison and
trying to pour poison down your gullet
trying to to give you weird Frankenstein
lab-grown meat which we'll get to
tomorrow don't have time to get to that
today all those people are on the left
and we do not want what they are selling
today is music Monday the rest of the
show continues now Mr Davies and the
producing team
has some really profound music for me to
analyze because you know I am a cultural
Maven I am this the hip-hop pippity pop
kind of music man over here you don't
want to miss it become a member and use
code Knowles Canada wlas at checkout for
two months free on all annual plans
we'll see you over there
[Music]
oh
foreign